[Music]
hello
my name is alan fader and i am a
principal data scientist at invesco
my talk today is about categorical
embeddings
and the embed package in r if you are
trying to create a predictive model
you'd really like to use all of the
variables in your data set
as that what is like that's what's
likely to create the most
accurate and successful predictions
but you may soon run into a problem
because many of the functions
within r that are used to create these
models
require that all of the input data are
continuous
numbers now this makes sense
because many of the computations that go
on in the background
work on linear algebra and matrices
which inherently can only have numbers
in them
but that might be a problem for you
because some of your data might be
categorical variables
and you don't want to have to drop them
you might try
to replace each category with
a number one two three which might work
if your data is ordinal but if your data
doesn't have
in any inherent order to it this might
not work
if your one of your categories is color
how are you going to choose numbers
for black brown yellow or green
you might try to create dummy variables
but
this actually can cause big data
problems
really quick dummy variables will create
a new
variable for each level of your data
and for example if one of your
categories is united states zip code
you're about to add
42 000 new variables to your data and
that's
probably not what you want that leads me
to categorical embeddings
if you're familiar with word embeddings
such as word to back this is actually a
very similar idea
except instead of an embedding for each
word
in language you're embedding each
category in your data
what happens is that every category is
replaced by a vector of numbers
the vector can be length 4 it can be
length 50 it really depends on the
situation
but these numbers will replace your
categorical variable
for any future modeling now
categorical variables are most commonly
fit by
neural networks which is why within r
many of the most common ways of
creating them are using the keras or in
tensorflow packages
or the new torch package however i find
the simplest
way to do it is with the embed package
which is one of the add-on packages
in the tidy model's suite of packages
for example let's say you had a data set
of sales transactions
and you wanted to predict which
transactions are fraudulent and which
ones are not
having product in there you can imagine
how that would help
the predictive ability of the model but
with over 4 500
unique products that's going to cause
problems with creating your model
but with the embed package all you have
to do
is add one function step and bed
onto a tidy model's recipe to create
this embedding
once you've prepped this recipe the
embeddings are there for use
and you can see here how each product is
now represented
by an embedding of four numbers and
these four numbers
are going to replace the old product
category
within the data going forward you can
now use this
for any downstream model it doesn't even
have to be a neural network
you could also use this if you wanted
just to explore your data further
and learn more about the products maybe
you could use cosine similarity
to figure out which products are most
similar to each other
now there's obviously a ton more that i
could talk about with categorical
embeddings
it's a topic that i find really exciting
i hope you learn and discover more about
categorical embeddings
as you use them within your modeling
thank you very much for coming and good
[Music]
luck
you